all right Chino Chino uh where you from
originally where'd you grow up uh I grew
up uh boy Idaho Bo Idaho yeah but I was
born in Boise Idaho till I was the age
of 11 or
12 and uh moved back well moved to
California uh Cella
Valley Cella California there's where my
mother's from the and all our family was
there and so from that age on I I lived
in in Coachella and tell me about your
family growing up uh my father um was
a a hardworking man but he was a a a
drug dealer you know a very big drug
dealer and in in what state uh he was
working in five
states uh in 1979 he was arrested by by
the the
feds uh and he received a sense of 30
years in Idaho State penetentiary
and so um that drug dealing uh is a big
thing in in our family and my dad's side
of the
family and so
uh uh I always I grew up around as as
far as I can remember you know drugs
smelling
marijuana uh seeing
guns and sometimes seeing my dad beat
somebody
up and so it was just uh something that
I thought was normal you until just
recently so your family has an
interesting history with another family
yes the forest family uh uh my dad's
family it started with my dad's dad you
you know and early
1900s uh they lived in um Matamoros
Mexico and it's like any other family
feud basically I'm not I've heard two
different versions that it was over a
woman and over
land you know and as I did research on
it that's normally where these family Fe
started over you know back in the days
either a woman or or land there's
usually a woman involved yeah and so um
it was uh and it's interesting
because as the years progress
um the families moved to Texas and the
family ends up in Texas and then the
family ends up in the Coachella Valley
and the other family ends up in
Coachella Valley you know how I I don't
know how that happened you know but um
they were
uh any chance they got they were
fighting and and of course when when
you're
fighting uh and and have that much
hatred towards each other uh people die
you know and that's what was going on uh
every time I remember when I moved to
Cella and I introduced myself to certain
people they would be like oh you're who
your dad's Chino that's your dad oh my
God that's a good man that man's
dangerous they were when the Flores
family and the Mata families were at the
dances or the parties they knew you know
there was going to be
Bloodshed and so it was it was like that
for for many many years and so there
were murders oh yeah uh yeah there was
murders on both
sides you know casual well I we call it
casualties you know cuz it was like a
war I guess but uh uh I wasn't even born
at at that time yet you know I was born
in 7
1 and my father um from what I I read
and and heard I think in 70 in 66
67 he
killed uh Mr Flores the dad and his
oldest son uh at a bar in Indio
California and it was
because they were making fun of my dad's
little brother that they had murdered a
couple weeks prior to this uh that's
what I was telling you about they were
at a dance and some woman took him
outside and uh the florish guys were out
there waiting and they stabbed him to
death and threw him in the
dumpster and so um my dad was at that
bar and uh they were very drunk uh the
florish guys and they were making
comments
and
laughing so my dad left but he didn't
leave he just went to his out to his
truck and uh sat there and waited and
waited and waited till these two drunk
men came out and as soon as they came
out he just pulled right he was like
sitting a block away at the corner
watching the
door and they walk out he drives right
up wend rolls down and shoots them
both and uh he was
arrested and uh found not guilty in
court not guilty not guilty how'd that
happen I have no idea
well my mother says that uh rest in
peace my mom poor mama she uh uh went to
Mexicali and went to go talk to
uh uh
what do you call them
people a witch
or you know something like that you know
that's what she told me I remember she
said she had to go to um Mexicali and
pay some money and and talk to some lady
and she told him that he would be found
out guilty and and he was H
so I don't know I don't know if it was
my mom's prayers which I believe is it
probably was the prayers more than that
lady and so uh my dad eventually was uh
told to leave the state of
California and the family separated uh
five brothers went to Arizona and five
brothers went to
Idaho and that was part of
the the the the business of of drug
dealing they had going on you know you
know part of the family up north and the
other part down
south and that's
um how I was born in in in Boise in
1971 you know and uh I remember coming
to
California uh on many trips we've come
uh as a family visit the family and and
drive back you know we would fly o fly
over or uh drive over but mainly fly and
then drive back you know cars were uh
loaded with dope
probably and I think it was the year 79
maybe
uh we were driving
back and I remember seeing this red
Trans Am you know following us I seen it
in in IND I seen it in Sacramento
because we stopped in Sacramento and I
seen it again in a little town called
the wind and Mona
Nevada and I told my father cuz my
father would always tell me you what you
see you don't say nothing and if you see
something tell me you know you'll know
if something's not right if you see a
cop or some guy's looking over here or
taking pictures let me know so I told my
dad this car is following us and
immediately uh he went to straight to a
motel uh unloaded the the car and and
told me come on let's drive around let
me know if you see the car and then he
drove to the police station and he was
looking around the police station see if
you see that car and we went in the
police station and he was
asking for about road conditions you
know cuz it was uh snowing at that time
and but I didn't see that car again
again I didn't see that car again until
we got home and
Boise uh I was not even made it out of
the back seat I was so excited to be
home I wanted to ride my bike I remember
and when all hell broke
loose I mean officers came I don't know
how they got there so fast and where
they came
from and that was the the day my father
got arrested and my mother you know and
you were
whole at that time I was
probably seven or
eight seven or
eight yeah me and my sister I have a
sister it's just me and her and uh she's
18 months younger than
me but she's you more like the older
sister you know and uh we were put in
into a I guess Foster you know foster
home you know we we're staying with some
people for a while and until my mother
got
released it was only a couple weeks but
it seemed like years at that time when I
was a
kid and uh my father got sentenced to 30
years in
prison and uh poor man uh died on his
seventh year I think of
cancer uh I got to see him the the
Governor Lio gave him uh clemency
pardon uh because he was dying you know
uh he died within 80 Days of that
release it it ate him up really really
fast he didn't he didn't uh like
doctors you know my father was a type of
uh a man that he cured everything with
tequila and lemon that was his his his
medicine
and
so um the the the the feud you know I I
I
was we after my dad got arrested we
stayed there I think in Idaho like three
to four years uh we had no family over
there no family whatsoever no no blood
relatives or nothing it was just my
mother my sister and myself my father in
prison and uh
my mom lived or we lived um with money
they had buried I guess stashed that
lasted a couple years and when that
money ran out uh we were on welfare and
it was very difficult for my mom and she
was very young you know I think about it
and add up the years she was like 24 25
at that time you know she had been with
my dad since she was 13 years old you
know uh my dad was I think 17 or 19 you
know at that when they got
together and he passed away at
42 and uh and then my mother passed away
when she was
45 and it's been 30 years already
they've been gone were there other
murders in this Feud oh yeah yeah there
was
um I talked to my uncles and and family
members and cousins that's like I say I
got a huge family my mom's family is Big
my dad's family is big and it's um it's
a it's a my dad's family is you know
drug addicts drug dealers and gang
members my moms are police officers and
Military you know Ed going to college
and education and jobs and it's just two
different so they always kept me away
from uh my uh my father father's side
until I was 16 I 15 old enough where I
could just go on my own and what path
did you take I took the my father's path
you know
um I would go both I I mean but I I I
took my father's you know uh you've
ended up in uh prison oh yeah I
um from wanting to be a baseball star
becoming uh wanting to be a gang member
overnight you know I I remember
uh uh seeing one of my cousins getting
out of
prison typical prisoner gang member you
know all buff yolked up tattoos
everywhere very calm very
respectful and I seen how people treated
him and uh it remind reminded me of my
dad you know I kind of saw that and uh
and that's what I wanted you know I I
wanted it really
bad and
uh and and I got it I got it you know I
kind of achieved what I wanted um to
this day I I I can't believe
that I wanted to go to prison and I
wanted to go to the shoe and and it's
just I don't know I I I
can't I can't believe I I put myself
through through that you know I did a
lot of years in in in uh the shoe and
solitary
confinement you know U wow
it's it's amazing it's just
very very difficult you know that I
didn't lose my
mind and that I'm I'm able still to
function because I I seen a lot of guys
that lost their mind being and in in the
shoe the shoe is the solitary
confinement yeah solit it's called the
security housing unit
shoe and so you know it was very rough I
was I was there I don't know if you ever
heard uh in the '90s they had in Parr
prison uh they were St they were staging
fights the officers embedding on it FBI
got involved and all kind of and then
shooting us you know uh sometimes with
the non-lethal round and sometimes with
with a a a live
round and uh it was Madness you know I
used to have to go out every 10 days and
fight you know cuz when every time you
went out and you got a write up or or in
trouble you were confined to quarter for
10 days you know we didn't come out
anyways but you you just couldn't come
out for 10 days you know and every 10
days it was your turn again you know it
10 days to maybe you got lucky cuz
depending how many people were on that
tier you know or eligible to go out and
there was a lot of Mexicans and a
Mexicans where it's mandatory for us to
turn on our light to go out cu they they
tell you turn on your lights you want
yard and officers would come and policy
is they go to the first cell and you you
want to go outside they take them and go
to the next cell but they would go and
and they knew who the enemies were they
had a list and so they would go to this
cell and and take one or two of them out
and then come and get one two or four of
these guys out you know and staging
these fights and you would look up in
the tower and there would
be there would be a lot of people up
there and there's only supposed to be
one or two it's like entertainment for
the it was yeah they were betting they
were
gambling you know and and and we're over
here doing it
for for an extra sack lunch or something
you know or coffee packs you know that's
what we used to give
us and uh
yeah it was it was
uh
very at first it was it was it was a lot
of um
anxiety you know knowing that tomorrow I
got to go out and and and fight and
possibly get shanked or or shot or beat
up you know and and you would know basic
who you're you were going to go out with
you know because your enemy is uh also
talking on the tier to you know their
boss or shop caller whoever
and and you know they're telling him you
make sure you kick his ass and you know
do this and do
that uh and so it was
uh it was it was a crazy life so far I'm
53 have drugs been a part of your life
yeah I'm I I've been using drugs since I
was 11 m what is your drug currently uh
right now I use um opiates uh fentanyl I
smoke Fentanyl and uh uh smoke Crystal
math and smoke
[Music]
marijuana and um how do you make money
uh right now I I sell dope uh I steal I
shoplift I I don't do burges I don't
steal from people are you
homeless
um yes or
no I'm I'm married and um we we have a
house and but I'm never there you know
me and my wife we constantly fight
so uh there's a lot of times uh I just
stay out in the streets you know uh I go
home take a shower get some
clothes try to talk to her and it it's
just it's not working you know our
relationship is is is is not there no
more the you know I ruined the marriage
you know we've been together about 25
years and um I I love her to
death and she doesn't believe that and
so
uh I got out of prison four years
ago and I was sneaking around but I was
it's cuz I was hiding I was doing drugs
and she thought I was cheating you know
and uh I didn't know nobody down here so
it was hard for me I have to go out
sneak out and go find at that time I was
using
heroin uh I've always been a heroin
addict I injected heroin and um I just
got tired of it because I had no more
veins and I was getting a lot of
infections and um every part of my body
hurt you know it was bruis here bruis
there and it it was just uh I was sick
of it you know but I I love um the
feeling of O
opiates uh I I say I was born addicted
you know I that's what I I I know it's a
cop maybe a cop
out but um I was uh I think my mother
used when when uh I was in her stomach
do you have children I have a daughter
one daughter she's her name's
Serena uh she's currently I think
in Phoenix or back in India with her
mother I haven't seen her in a long time
time
she's 32 I
think she what's come of the uh the feud
between your family and the Flores
family um the well that went it like I
say it went off for years and years and
years and uh when I came to California
in
85 1985 I came to California and the
Flores had already basically died out
you know there was from what I hear
there was uh one
left um and he was an old
man and and a sister they had a
sister and
um the sister had a couple of sons and
and I knew them guys you know we became
I met them and I didn't know they were
related to they were flores's I didn't
know that's who they were
um but uh I ended up talking to uh the
the the lady the mom the
sister uh cuz I was going out with her
daughter it's it's just ironic how weird
life is you know I I met this chick and
and we're going out and I had my last
name mat tattooed on my stomach when I
was 13 and I had my shirt off it was
summer hot and the mom came out and I
remember that look she just like looked
at me and looked at my tattoo and she
started screaming
you know she was screaming the Matas are
here they're com to kill us and it was
just me and you know I was just there
with you know trying to be with her
daughter you know young teenagers was
that the end of that
relationship uh no no it wasn't you know
um that girl ended up getting with one
of my other
cousins and um had like six seven kids
with him and you you know part of the
family but the the the the
War
uh it's it it stopped I
guess there cuz I remember talking to uh
her
sons and they were like confused you
know uh cuz they didn't have no more
uncles you no one left a fight no one
yeah they didn't have nobody and so they
knew a little bit about the the the
Family
Feud and they were seriously thinking
well should we is it should we continue
it should we you know avenge our family
members and I remember hearing him you
know saying this you know it was two
brothers they were talking you
know and I was like you guys are crazy
you know there's still hundreds of us
you know our family is
huge huge I would love to find out how
many there is of us I remember going
to uh a party for my
grandfather
and one of the his daughters made a a
family
tree and uh there was like 500 names on
that
tree you know that my grand grandfather
and grandmother they were
responsible for these 500 lives you know
because of them you know and I remember
seeing my name right there and I was
like wow
that's and and I know that it's grown
way it's grown a lot more you know the
family is still big what would you say
is your biggest regret in your
life oh man I really always said I had
no regrets but that's a lie
um my biggest regret would be
um using
drugs you know uh drugs
is uh been um a part of my life and I
I've I've at the age I am now I I I've
come to realize
that everything that's happened to me
negative everything I've ever happened
bad it was because of drugs even in
prison you know I've been
stabbed uh I've been put in the the the
Hole uh being written up and it was all
over drugs you know uh I lost jobs
opportunities good opportunities I've
been blessed with many opportunities and
I would lose them and over my over my
drug
addiction and so I I I I figure um
that's my biggest regret because if I
didn't do drugs uh I'd probably be a
police
officer you know what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life the most important lesson I've
learned in my
life is
um
wow you
know you have to love your
family you know you you have
to
um you have to do good you know all all
that the the the evil and all the bad
stuff
um it it really could
um
whoa just too much bad
stuff uh you've seen a lot of it in your
family
yeah there's been a lot of bad
stuff
so I just figure
um you know I I I'm I I'm like one day
I'm here one day I'm over here you know
I'm good I'm
bad uh I like good
better and
um it's just been too
much too much
um man I can't believe
this
whoa you know
uh when my uncle the youngest of the
family uh was killed by the Flores
family back in the 60s when she lured
them outside there was I think we we
heard it was three or four Flores
Brothers out there and they all stabbed
him you know so he was stabbed to death
and and thrown in a in in a trash can a
dumpster and you know the stabbing is is
is one thing but to the family uh
throwing his body in that
dumpster that was
like disrespect to to the fullest and uh
that's where my father uh
you know he he took things into my
father was like the second dad of the
family my dad was the oldest of of the
family and so I I talked to my aunts and
I always how was my dad and they say oh
your dad was
mean you know your dad man he was mean
and so she goes we used to have to ask
him permission to go out to do anything
he was like our father you know he was
the one in charge and so
um my dad I like to say um wasn't even
involved no more with the the the Family
Feud like
handson you know um he was still
young uh but he was in in in in love
with my
mother and um
so uh they they they killed U my uncle
his baby brother and his dad was still
alive at that time my
grandfather and he um from what I
hear uh told his sons that he wanted
that
killed he wanted her
head and two of his sons um drove to
Arizona found this lady and and killed
her and chopped her head
off and uh
they got caught you know and they got
caught with the
head and they were both sentenced to um
life terms in in in in
Arizona and then um they committed more
murders in in in prison and were
ultimately put on death
row and my uncle
was executed uh by the state of Arizona
by lethon Jackson in
1998 and um my other uncle was released
from death row and put back on General
Pop I guess but with uh life
without and uh he did 50 he was on 52nd
year in prison and they released him but
you he was an old man in his 80s already
he got arrested I think when he was
19 so he spent all his adult life in
prison he is an old man and uh he got
released and the family brought him from
Arizona to California to
Pella and he was just he was something
else you know he just wanted to be the
boss you know um and and nobody could
put up with him they were they were
taking turns he would go live over here
then go live over there and go live over
here and uh he just got fed up himself I
guess and and he left and he was back in
Arizona homeless on the street really
old and drunk and
um my my uncle uh Juan I'm close to him
uh he uh went looking for his brother
you know he heard that he was homeless
and looking for him so we drove over
there to Arizona looking for him and we
didn't find him we came back home and
like maybe we went back out two or three
weeks later on the weekend we drove back
over there and uh we located him we
found him and it was it was a it was
horrible you know he didn't have no
shoes on no socks uh he was really
skinny uh real fragile you know and my
uncle uh
took off his shoes and his
socks and gave it to
him remember
that and told him you know what are you
doing just you you just get in in the
van and let us take you back home and um
you don't got nothing to worry about you
know he liked his music so he goes you
could have your music and your beer and
and and your marijuana your weed and you
can sit on the porch all day long and
and that's all you got to do don't worry
about
nothing but uh that that was not him you
know he he wanted to be the
boss and my aunts could not put up with
that you know so they were always like
you got to take him somebody's got to
help you know he's telling me what to do
I I'm not his wife and and that's what
he was used to I found out that uh both
of my uncles over there were also um
involved in in um and some hardcore uh
prison
politics uh and so uh he was you know
used to being in
charge and at the end of the day he he
went back he went back to prison he
chose to go back yeah and it's weird
because I was like how what do you mean
he went back you know how does that
work well because of his
crimes and everything and the crimes he
committed while in in prison
uh
um the the only reason they released him
is cu he's old you know but they were
making the family pay money Arizona was
making them
pay I guess they prison didn't even want
him you you know they they know him you
know he's well known in in the prison
system over there in in Phoenix Arizona
I think he was in
Flagstaff and so uh uh I asked my uncle
what what's up with him and he said he's
he's there he's still alive he's he's
sick right now you know uh he's like
90 you know old old man but
um he he's institutional to the fullest
that's what he's been doing for his
whole life since he was
19 violence is a rough life yeah you
know very rough very very rough and I
feel sorry for him you know I really do
and I was leading in that in that path
you know
um I'm
and I started getting arrested when I
was 15
you know and uh being
supervised uh I'm off parole now and
this is the first time since I was 15
that I'm not
supervised and and it's it's it's it's
good you
know uh I gave back my number I had an H
number and I had that number for 30
years uh I did a total of 27 years 28
years and and um California's Department
of Corrections and
Rehabilitation um my last term was
almost 20 years I did it like 19 years 9
months what was that
for
um it was for being stupid you know um
burglary you know burglar I didn't even
commit and uh but just because of my
name and and my
my record I I say my record but I I I
mean I had a record but it wasn't like I
had been in prison a lot you know I went
to prison one time uh for robbery and
assault with a deadly weapon that was my
uh they call controlling
case so right there that gave me two
strikes this was way before the three
strike law came in
effect and so when I get arrested um on
this last term in
2000 uh I have two strikes and then with
these new charges I have you know three
new felonies and so they want to give me
75 to life and I I was in the county
jail for over 3 years stressed out you
know thinking I was going to die in
prison and and I that's I didn't want
that I I that's one thing that that I
feared the most was you know dying alone
in
prison because uh when you get hurt or
anything in they don't call your family
you know they call your family not even
when you die sometimes they don't even
the family don't find out for weeks you
know that you've been dead and so um I
I've been close to dying I have ODed in
prison and and should have died that
night you know I did I mean to if your
heart stops I guess you know I died and
came back you know um I got stabbed and
uh basically bled out I you know but the
doctors uh saved my life that
time and so I've been through a lot of
other
um uh stuff in in in prison you know I
was always on maximum security yards
level
fours
um uh you know trying to be
um a tough guy a wise
guy but you know you at a there comes a
time where you you plateau you know you
can only go so
high up in the ladder you know
and you got there's one step left you
know and I couldn't take that last step
you
know and so
um that that career was over you know uh
I I couldn't go anymore I couldn't get
any
higher and so uh there was no need for
me anymore to follow that path you know
it was time for me to take another path
another
journey and and and and find something
uh worth worth doing you know something
positive
uh as I as I got older as the years went
on
uh you know now you the regrets you know
they they start hitting you you know
you're you're you're
missing so much when you're in prison
time
stops you know
um time stops I I
was 43 years
old when it hit
me that I was 43 I thought I was
22 you know
and I was acting like I was 22 and but I
wasn't I I was it just hit me like I'm
43 years
old I got to change I got to act
different you know I I I need to dress
different just I got to do something
different you know and and I have to
give up the
drugs and that's been that's been very
very hard for me you know um I love them
and I hate
them you know
um but I am smarter now I am
wiser um I'm
more
compassionate you know uh more
humble um I still have temper problems I
guess you know I get really angry really
fast and uh I don't I I try to stay away
from that that part of
me because
uh you know I've been involved in a lot
of stuff you know so I I tell myself I I
can't I'm not going to be the
victim you know I can't be the
victim and so if I feel a threat or you
know anything
uh I I I I strike I do what I have to do
and uh I don't like that you
know uh I I believe in in in Jesus
Christ I believe in
karma you know
and
uh and it's it's true you know I
wasn't I was involved in
um 11 incidents in prison you know
and one day I counted how many times
I've been stabbed and I have 11 holes in
me on three three separate you know
attacks on me uh they add up to 11
holes so you know that shows me that
Karma's for
Real uh and so I started um being nicer
to
people you I didn't have to uh I
realized that I didn't have to
be mean mug you know be so serious all
the time that I could laugh and joke
around it was okay
you know uh a lot after that a lot of
people told me like
man I always would see you over there by
yourself doing your exercises and I
would just think man that guy is mean
you know that guy could probably kill me
and then they they see the real me you
know happy gold lucky guy laughing all
the
time um a guy that cares you know I
generally care about people
uh I I I don't care if he's black white
Chinese um if I could help somebody I'll
help them you know is that a better life
for
you oh yeah it is it is
um uh you know I'm I'm still uh addicted
to drugs so that still brings me around
the negative and and the evil you know
and even though I try to stay away you
can't if you're involved in that and
you're around that kind of U
environment
um you you're going to have to sooner or
later face what comes with it you know
and
um but I I I I still love the people I
love the you know the drug addicts you
know some of the nicest people the
homeless you know I hang around a lot of
homeless people and uh my my wife would
you know she would say stuff about that
but just recently she started um knowing
some people and she said the nicest
people she's met are the
homeless you know they the homeless have
helped us you know the homeless have fed
us you know and and that just you know
just because they got don't have a house
doesn't mean there's something wrong
with them you know they're they're
people they're they're they're humans
they're
Americans and we have to look out for
each
other and so
um uh I I do whatever I can for whoever
ask me for help and and my wife likes it
and she hates it it drives her
crazy um
CU I I she feels I I I pay more
attention to uh other people than her
you know she doesn't get it you know I
love her to death
but I ruin the marriage you
know all right Chino thank you so much
for sharing your story yes uh thank you
for having me I wish you lots of luck
from here out sir thank
you